un tiers de la production mondiale est
jeté c'est devenu la pure consommation
et et on fait un peu n'importe quoi dans
le monde près d'un milliard et demi de
tonnes de nourriture est gaspillée
chaque année l'équivalent de 22 millions
de repas c'est vrai qu'on enchaîne
tellement la rupture avec ce que
l'europe jette chaque année à elle seule
un milliard de personnes pourraient être
nourri soit l'intégralité de ceux qui
souffrent de la malnutrition dans le
monde
les jours on gaspille sans compter en
fait chez nous en france 10 millions de
tonnes d'aliments partent à la poubelle
tous les ans en termes de poids ça fait
quand même 150 tour eiffel on est
souvent là en train de gaspiller alors
que les choses soient encore bonne
chaque français jette plus de 20 kg de
nourriture comestible par an dont 7 kg
encore emballés
au total près de 500 euros par an
pendant ce temps là un français sur cinq
ne peut pas manger trois repas par jour
faute de moyens suffisants
alors on s'est demandé la région centre
val de loire dans tout ça
même chiffre même constat c'est l'ademe
qui nous l'a affirmé alors on y croire
toutes ces personnes ont un coût pour
nous consommateurs mais pas seulement
pour la grande distribution par exemple
ou alors la restauration collective et
cet argument commence à convaincre des
professionnels de lutter contre ce
gaspillage alimentaire à vendôme
isabelle racine a rencontré un
distributeur chez qui certains fruits et
légumes échappe de justesse à la
poubelle et sont même rentabiliser
regardé plusieurs fois par jour c'est le
même rituel dans ce magasin de produits
biologiques
il faut trier les fruits et les légumes
cette pomme qui est abîmée et acheter on
peut appeler ça du pourri effectivement
nous on n'a pas le droit de la vendre
comme ceci donc même un prix plus bas au
plus attractif en objet de la retirer du
rayon pour éviter de jeter
frédéric d'air à trouver une solution
donnée marie la récolte deux jours à
transformer et c'est parti il faut laver
éplucher tranché puis disposer sur des
grilles direction le déshydrateur à 50
degrés pour enlever toute l'eau mais
conserver vitamines et minéraux
impeccable effectivement 8h de
déshydratation on va pouvoir les enlever
c'est ainsi que fruits du moment et
légumes de saison trouvent une seconde
vie et une nouvelle place en rayon
c'est du gagnant gagnant il fallait
juste y penser
la démarche est simple l epa et dha
économique et surtout écologique
on va bientôt arriver à diviser
2 nos déchets très prochainement sur
depuis trois mois d'activité sur la
déshydratation
donc tu penses que le chaland déjà gagné
et on a d'autres projets effectivement
pour arriver je veux pas dire au zéro
déchet mais qui reste plus que le pourri
dans la poubelle
ces projets proposés ses clients des jus
frais de légumes ou de fruits des soupes
aussi car vous l'avez compris je t'ai
c'est un geste qu'il ne veut plus faire
depuis le 30 mai 2018 la loi impose un
diagnostic aux restaurations collectives
mais l'hôpital de blois n'a pas attendu
cette voie pour le réaliser et dr film
c'était nécessaire c'était nécessaire
tout le monde sait en fait que lorsqu'on
est malade la première chose qui ne va
pas c'est l'appétit d'agnostiques a
montré qu'en moyenne on avait 40% de nos
assiettes qui était mis à la poubelle
rapporté à l'échelle de l'hôpital de
blois ses 240 et quelques tonnes qui
partent à la poubelle chaque année pour
une valeur de l'emballement millions
d'euros quand même et face à ce
diagnostic vous avez mis en place un
plan d'action absolument plan d'action
plusieurs axes quatre grands axes de
d'actions qui vont concerner la qualité
nutritionnelle l'organisation dû donner
à manger aux personnes la formation des
professionnels et la communication
autour du techno style du gaspillage que
nous avons organisées en à peine un an
on a déjà quelques résultats très
positifs alors si on parle de chiffres
économiques je pense qu'on a réduit de à
peu près un tiers le gaspillage
initialement diagnostiqués alors
monsieur je pas débarrassé plateau
quelles ont été les actions qui ont été
mises en place en oncologie première
action le coût déjeuner le matin 7h ami
le petit déjeuner donc on termine sur
les coups de 8 heures annie donc les
gens beaucoup plus d'appétit le midi
donc consomment beaucoup plus leur
assiette donc moins de gaspillage
alimentaire ensuite le soir s'est aperçu
que la soupe était un coupe-faim
donc on a enlevé la soupe et les gens
consomment beaucoup plus leur plateau
qui leur est indispensable pour
pour eux donc voilà les actions propres
traits programme on est on est on est
voilà on part sur du 6 kilos en moins
pratiquement par jour 2 de gaspillage
les gaspillage alimentaire dans les
poubelles
le gaspillage alimentaire contribue
également au réchauffement climatique
un kilo de nourriture produits équivaut
à 4 tino et demi de co2 rejeté dans
l'atmosphère
l'objectif des pouvoirs publics est de
diminuer de 50% ce gaspillage
alimentaire d'ici 2025 si cela dépend
des professionnels bien sûr mais de nous
aussi consommateurs nous pouvons avoir
un réel impact en adoptant de nouvelles
pratiques de consommation